joël allègre bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france à leur
première question que cherche à faire
recep tayyip erdogan avec cet appel au
boycott et les accusations portées à
l'encontre d'emmanuel map rond il
s'emballe dans une ligne qui poursuit
depuis déjà un certain temps donc il
s'adresse d'abord aux turcs
en fait en essayant de leur montrer que
non seulement il défend très bien les
intérêts de la turquie mais en plus les
intérêts de l'islam et ça fait longtemps
qu'il poursuit cette tendance et qu'il a
oublié la laïcité de mustafa kemal mêmes
qui l'a démoli et des faits un certain
nombre de lois qui est mal dans ce sens
pour créer en même temps ils essayent de
s'adresser à tous les musulmans si
possible du proche-orient en prenant
après avoir pris la place du sultan en
prenant la place du calife
justement est ce qu'aujourd'hui r2 est
né dans un rôle voulu celui de héros
populiste de l'islam politique à la fois
face aux monarchies du golfe comme
l'arabie saoudite et en même temps
mobiliser les états qui soutiennent
d'islam politique comme le qatar par
exemple a indéniablement il a déjà la
turquie a des relations étroites avec le
qatar est indéniablement il est dans son
rôle il le cultive
il est comme trempe il a abandonné tous
les ans toutes formes de langage
je dirais diplomate 1 pour passer plus
ou moins à l'injure mais ça fait des
années qu il le fait il s'est d'abord
accusé mais il a d'abord accusé tous
ceux qui étaient contre lui à
l'intérieur de la turquie en des termes
qui n'était pas du tout ni pauline du
diplomate ni rien il a manié d'injures
contre la grèce depuis déjà pas mal de
temps et ben maintenant s'est il passé
au stade supérieur
ces macro cette crise est elle
évitables selon vous à condition de
s'aplatir et de ne rien dire enfin je
veux dire que quand macro on parle de l'
influence d'erdogan sur la construction
de mosquées à l usage des tours de
france sur la formation des imams qui
l'envoie en france et cetera il dit
vérité donc évidemment si on ne dit pas
cette vérité on évite de déplaire à leur
domaine mais il faut savoir aussi jusqu
où on veut aller dans le shark pas de
bug
jusqu'où peut aller cette crise est ce
que vous pensez que voilà certains pays
qui soutiennent l'islam politique peut
également aller dans ce sens avoir des
mots très durs envers la france on parle
du boycott bien évidemment de certains
produits français mais en même temps se
pose la question des investissements de
ces pays là en france comme le qatar par
exemple les investissements du qatar
fonds qu'effectivement on est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile face à
lui en même temps ces investissements
sont supposés quand même et il les a
passées par bonté d'âme sont quand même
supposer rapporté donc le qatar lui même
a intérêt à ce que on en arrive pas au
dernier degré de la rupture
je crois que tous les états musulmans à
l'intérieur pour leurs opinions
intérieure ont intérêt effectivement a
critiqué la position française
d'autant plus que les turcs de turquie
par exemple ne savent pas grand chose de
ce qui est vraiment la position
française c'est-à-dire imagine par
exemple que le voile est interdit
partout que personne ne peut le porter
même dans la rue sans avoir des ennuis
l'abominable quand il parle de la
situation des juifs
avant la seconde guerre mondiale en
europe et qui compare ça avec la
condition des musulmans en france
je veux dire son opinion publique qui ne
sait rien que le croire c'est tout le
monde sait très bien que vraiment il ya
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
comparaison possible mais n'a jamais
voulu accepter la distinction que macron
a essayé de faire désespérément entre
musulmans et islamistes politiques
alors aujourd'hui on voit vraiment voilà
la ligne 2 de recep tayyip erdogan alors
qu'il ya quelques années il se présente
est peut-être comme quelqu'un qui prône
l' islam modéré on se rappelle que la
turquie voulait également faire partie
de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui après
voilà ses attaques envers emmanuel
macron plusieurs pays européens ont
apporté leur soutien au président
français voudrait-il aujourd'hui une
réponse commune de la part de l'europe
pour justement isoler la turquie un
petit peu plus mais il ya longtemps il
faudrait une réponse commune face à ce
problème là et à d'autres d'ailleurs
mais le problème de grands problèmes de
l'europe si qu'elle n'a pas de position
diplomatique commune sur quasiment rien
le problème de l' unanimité fait que la
plupart des choses
hormis les déclarations de principe
quand on passe au à la pratique il ya
toujours quelque part un joke âge
dernière question emmanuel macron a
tenté un petit peu d'apaiser la
situation
en diffusant un message en anglais en
français en arabe sur twitter en disant
que nous étions unis qu'il fallait faire
une distinction bien évidemment entre
l'islam et l'islam politique est ce que
vous pensez que voilà des pays arabes
justement peuvent aller dans ce sens et
apporter leur soutien au président
français je je pense que c'est c'est un
message qui n'est qui est difficile à
comprendre pour pour ces pays qui vivent
en fait dans une atmosphère où la
distinction entre islam d'un islam
politique n'existe plus elle existe
encore pour les kémalistes qui
subsistent encore en turquie il mais qui
n'ont pas droit à la parole elle
subsiste pour un certain nombre de
de musulmans au maroc en tunisie etc
mais là aussi ont souffert ou eux mêmes
de cet islam politique certains pays qui
qui ont vécu le printemps arabe la
tunisie l'egypte ont souffert de cet
islam politique bien sûr mais je suis en
souffrent d'ailleurs encore et je veux
dire les turcs eux encore kémaliste
souffre énormément depuis plusieurs
années sans qu'on s'en soit vraiment
tellement préoccupé merci beaucoup en
tout cas joel à la corde avoir répondu à
nos questions je vous rappelle que vous
êtes maître de conférence et mérite à
l'inalco l'institut national des langues
et civilisations orientales